los asistentes a esta fiesta se corean
entre sí en la pista de baile con pocas
mascarillas a la vista empujan la vida
nocturna está de vuelta y en pleno
apogeo para este artista local es
difícil de creer que unos meses atrás
estaba cantando solo frente a una cámara
y ahora estoy viendo este vídeo y me doy
cuenta de que estuve atrapado en casa
sin saber qué hacer
el 31 de diciembre de 2019 las
autoridades de salud de wuhan en
publicaron el primer aviso de alerta
sobre un virus desconocido un mes
después la ciudad de 11 millones de
habitantes fue aislada repentinamente
del resto de china mientras entraba en
un estricto bloqueo de 76 días
domínguez fue voluntario para ese
entonces enviaba comida a la gente que
estaba atrapada en sus casas
y en ese momento sólo podía comer una
comida al día no muchas personas se
ofrecieron como voluntarias así que
estaba muy ansioso era el tsja oliva
algunos regresaron a sus lugares de
origen como jan con juan esta vendedora
de comida en la calle no tenía un
ingreso fijo pero ahora aprecia el
tiempo que ha podido pasar con su
familia
y sencillas ya a lo largo de la pandemia
nuestra familia entera estuvo junta
fueron momentos muy preciados y estaban
muy felices ya ese país más importa de
acuerdo con las autoridades en wuhan no
ha habido reportes de casos transmitidos
localmente desde mayo pero todavía
quedan muchas preguntas sobre el origen
del virus en enero del próximo año
después de meses de negociaciones un
grupo de científicos internacionales irá
a buján para realizar una investigación
independiente